they're actually about to close this
location here at six o'clock much many
of these people have been waiting for
much
a long part of the day today many three
hours just look at this line that's
still here uh you can see they we just
heard someone announce that they're
going to be closing here in just a
moment but these people still have no
idea about that well the health district
is using data they're getting from these
testing sites like this to figure out
where to put
more testing sites
maybe i should have brought a book to
read people like brian lane spent more
time in the car than they wanted to
three hours and 42 minutes this was the
wait for a cobin 19 test at centennial
hills ymca bruce says he has no other
choice this time's moving way too slow
i'm in the hospitality business i've got
to test every week the latest surge is
impacting more areas of the valley take
a look at this map from during the spike
in cases in december of 2020 the red and
orange shaded areas show the hot spots
this map is from last week zip codes are
more red around the valley as more
people test positive obviously everybody
out in centennial hills is coming to
this one a health district
representative tells me they look at
data from the zip codes and factor it in
as to where they will put testing sites
two new major sites are set to open once
again at texas station and fiesta
henderson the raceway might be a good
spot you know that the football season
is over maybe a legion stadium something
along those lines where you can get like
more testers instead of one
individual doing it one testing the
county is also now partnering with
curative mobile sites appointments are
needed for these mobile locations this
southwest site at windmill library was
booked all week a representative tells
me they plan to open even more sites
lane says taking precautions might not
only save you from the virus but also
lines like this you know everybody's got
to do what they can to keep themselves
safe
now back out here live kirito who were
just uh talking about there just a few
moments ago they're actually opening two
new locations through the health
district this week one will be in
laughlin and also another one in sandy
valley as of this afternoon there were
still appointments available in sandy
valley that's about 50 minutes away
those appointments were for tomorrow
that's 50 minutes away from downtown las
vegas reporting live this evening joe
muller live local now